you
I'd like to call this conversation with
steve forbes to order
so I'm a professor here Chiron Skinner
I'm used to telling people what to do
I've noticed there are a lot of
grown-ups here so I will try not to be
too dictatorial but before I introduce
our speaker and president Cohen I'd like
to first of all welcome all of you on a
Friday afternoon to one of our
homecoming activities and to thank Hines
college in the humanities scholars
program for joining the center for
international relations and politics
with which I direct for this event there
are many people that think as well of
course president Cohen and the Provost
mark Hamlet the deans who are here all
of them and especially being Krishna and
John mahasti my department head John
Miller and a number of other people
throughout the university who worked on
this event sherry Hayes Tim Haggerty
Pieter Cohen Marianne more roses to
panic Amanda canard Jennifer Logan and
Deborah Taylor I'll stop there there are
others all of these colleagues have
helped throughout this event and others
that will take place over the weekend I
there's a lot to talk about with mr.
Forbes and I'll just start it's the rare
to see a publisher enter politics not
all publishers most publishers don't
enter American politics or politics
directly in an electoral sense of any
sort but mr Forbes did just that in
nineteen ninety six and two thousand
when he joined the field of Republican
candidates seeking to win the party's
nomination for presidential nomination
he was the victor in Delaware and in the
Arizona primaries and in 1996 and in
1999 he did something that no candidate
of a major party has ever done when he
announced his presidential bid via the
internet through Forbes 2000.com so he
held um he started a trend that
continues today in addition to his
political career he's a prolific writer
and thinker his column fact and comment
appears in every issue of Forbes
magazine and it's there that I first was
introduced to him when he was reviewing
one of my books about a decade ago in
his reviews of books and and other major
issues facing the country he makes bold
and incisive comments here's one that I
thought I pulled out that I thought
would be of interest in a column this
spring he declared that pressuring
Beijing about its currency is a
destructively futile exercise instead
Washington should be focusing on
substantive issues like China's trade
barriers to US imports we should also he
said pressure China to open its capital
markets he's talked about in these
columns every major issue not just
economic issues facing the United States
he not only talks about these issues in
the magazine on his column page but now
he gives verbal commentary on on
forbes.com he's the chairman and CEO of
Forbes media and the media empire is
expanding its all over the world and I
think you'll hear some about that today
and it's also at the forefront of the
new media technologies leading the way
for other media other publishing empires
in his spare time he has he writes books
and he's written at least four and in
those books he addresses his favorite
thing the flat tax capitalism innovation
entrepreneurship these are the major
themes of his writings and he is among
the as Daniel heninger of the Wall
Street Journal recently remarked he's
one of the few Republicans seniors left
senior people not senior and age but
senior an impact to talk about growth as
a crucial creative essential force
henninger writes a driver or American
prosperity and primacy so it's quite
appropriate that mr. Forbes would
deliver post midterm election remarks at
Carnegie Mellon this is one of the
moments in our nation's history when
issues of economic growth in public
Elsie intersect in powerfully positive
and some obvious ways and Carnegie
Mellon is appropriate venue for the
conversation because any conversation
about politics markets and Technology
ought to happen at Carnegie Mellon the
professional journey of president Jared
Cohen is just one example why that is
the case dr. Cohen has been president of
Carnegie Mellon since 1997 and in 2007
he was reappointed to a third five-year
term as president something that rarely
happens at American universities usually
by the fourth or fifth year there
they're deeply disliked but he's become
the FDR like in his his presidency it's
the immunity under his leadership CMU
has continued to rise in the national
and international rankings of research
universities his priorities have
contribute contributed to this fact they
include undergraduate education new
interdisciplinary initiatives
information technology the environmental
sciences biotechnology fine arts and the
humanities racial diversity among
students and faculty international
initiatives and importantly economic
development in southwest Pennsylvania so
it's my pleasure to help you start this
conversation with President Cohen and
mr. Steve Forbes
thank you very much Chiron for that
introduction I'm going to have to i use
that one again I think I but thank you
in particular for making this possible
Chiron has been a fantastic leader of
the center for international relations
and politics she has an amazing network
and even better she is very generous in
using it for the benefit of the
University and having Steve Forbes here
is just the latest example welcome Steve
we're delighted to have you here thank
you we'll start with I guess where
what's obvious and so on everybody's
mind Tuesday's Schillaci which is I
guess the official now White House label
for what happened on Tuesday your
thoughts on that its implications we
would like to hear that well first let
me thank Chiron thank you for having me
come here today and thank you and mr.
president your colleagues for making
this possible during these tough
economic times it's a nice to be able to
come and get free drinks and the free
food take it where you can but and then
the answer your question on the midterms
I think what we saw here was more than
just a change of a power or division of
power more than the normal so-called
midterm elections what has been somewhat
unheralded is that not only did the GOP
take the house when reduced the
Democratic strength there to levels not
seen since early the nineteen early
1930s but what happened in legislative
elections not since 1928 of the
Republicans done so well in state houses
for houses and lower houses around the
country and it wasn't so much a victory
for Republicans per se as it was a
reaction I think to the overreach of the
current administration more than the
overreach I think we're at a time when
Americans are going to are asking again
and examining again what is the role of
government
in this country since the New Deal in
the 1930s government has relentlessly
expanded even under republican
presidents they may have slowed the
growth they may put in pro-growth
economic policies but the Leviathan
still expanded and I think that is now
going to be reversed not in a negative
sense but re-examination of what is the
constructive role of government and I
think you're going to see distinction
made between government and big or obese
government and that is over each you
thought I think the Americans were
profoundly disturbed by the binge
spending levels of spending knutson seen
since World War two proportionally never
in peacetime the huge expansion in areas
like health care and in the financial
industry and other areas the legislation
those two pieces of legislation on
healthcare financial reform so-called
were disturbing not just in terms of the
size but in the way the language was
deliberately written it was vague
language which gives enormous latitude
and power to regulators in Washington
which is one reason why this recovery
has been the weakest in American history
from a severe recession traditionally
when you have a severe recession in this
country at least the initial snapback is
very strong and then the question
becomes can you sustain it back in the
1970s for example and none of you are
old enough to remember the 70s it's
called pandering tried it in politics
didn't work which is what here today but
when it went in the 1970s you had three
ever more severe recessions they'd be
followed by a quick snap back and then
they'd hit the wall in the early 80s
with the Reagan reforms get a recession
even more severe than this one in the
sense that unemployment went higher than
it has in this downturn but came back in
83 growth rates two to three times what
we have today and sustain it a very good
clip with the minor interruptions for
over 25 years and so I think one of the
key
reasons why this one has been such a low
gear recovery we're not going to have a
double-dip recession but it has not been
the kind of a vibrant one that
immediately get after a recession is a
no small part because the huge
uncertainties of what are the rules of
the game and I've had numerous people
restaurant tours especially come up to
me and airports and elsewhere in saying
if this bill isn't changed we're out of
it we cannot afford this and numerous
small businesses no reliable lines of
credit because of the distortions the
Fed has done to the banking system so it
wasn't just the spending per se it's the
feeling that this is not in the American
tradition we are not Western Europe and
so you got this severe reaction and I
think it's not an overnight thing we'll
see if the Republicans can ride this
thing and direct it in a positive way
but if they're seen as failing which
would be calm tea parties or others they
will go elsewhere they're not they're
not they're not adherence to political
parties a lot of young people are very
libertarian in there in there in their
feelings they're not adherence to
parties they want principles and
policies that result from those
principles and if one party is seen as a
flubbing it they won't hesitate to go
elsewhere a lot of things to follow up
on the TV let's start with jobs which
you mentioned today's jobs report was I
guess about what was expected the
unemployment rate stated nine point six
percent 150,000 jobs were created but
that's like 50,000 net but something new
that I picked up on and getting your
comments would be very valuable is the
workforce the total number of people in
the workforce decline I about two and
fifty thousand which is not a large
number given the size of the workforce
but apparently that's the first time
that's happened in many many years does
that signal in you are you concerned
about that and well I thinks I think
what's what you should concern people is
not just what they call discouraged
people in the labor force who drop out
of it or whatever reason is that the
reluctance of a people to hire they put
it off as long as they can next year we
will create probably one-and-a-half to
two million jobs but given the size of
the unemployment given the size of
underemployment that's pretty feeble
stark contrast to what you saw in the
80s and 90s and so again that gets to
why isn't this happen this is highly
unnatural they call this the new normal
I think that it's not normal it's
abnormal and the folks should be on why
why isn't why aren't we having more job
creation that that's the normal and it
gets to things like i mentioned what's
happened on health care what's happened
in the financial reform bill and the big
thing that gets not very much play
because it's the most boring subject in
the world it will put you to sleep as
soon as i mentioned the subject that is
monetary policy Federal Reserve interest
rates Ben Bernanke the eyelids already
begin to get heavy things and I told
some some of you just to give you a
travel tip if you ever find yourself in
an airplane in coach middle seat on the
runway watching your life pass away you
want a little bit of elbow room with
your seatmates start talking about
monetary policy or or if any of you have
any of you who are single a lot of young
people here today on a bad date than one
out talk about monetary policy you'll
never see that person again but but it
is it is the it is the one of those the
single biggest drag on the economy today
weak dollar means a weak recovery
whenever you trash your money whenever
you undermine the standard measure like
the value of a currency you get in big
trouble and if cheap money was the way
to wealth zimbabwe and argentine would
own the world today it should be a
steady measure of value it's not a
partisan thing this started under george
w bush this weak dollar policy
had a strong dollar policy Ronald Reagan
Republican had when John Kennedy
Democrat had one so it shouldn't be
partisan but something the Federal
Reserve today still believes you just
saw it this morning you know going to
buy another 600 billion of a dollar of
bonds which is just pushing a string
it's not a lack of liquidity in the
system it's the liquidity is not allowed
to go to work in a normal way because of
what the Fed is and others have done and
just to make it simple monetary policies
like your car you can have a magnificent
vehicle but if you don't have sufficient
fuel you're going to stall the engine
too much you flood the engine the right
amount you have a chance to move ahead
same is true of an economy and monetary
policy you have an economy of basic
strengths but if you don't supply
liquidity to meet the legitimate needs
of the market place you're going to
stall the thing if you supply too much
you get the economic equivalent of
flooding the engine the right amount you
can maybe move ahead long story short
the Fed has been flooding the engine
since the early part of the last decade
and that's why we got the housing bubble
could never have happened if you hadn't
supplied that liquidity a lot of other
distortions why have a lot of
speculation and commodities and
currencies capital flowing to Asia and
yet it just passes over their head in
Washington so that's a critical reason
why jobs aren't being created the lack
of investment lack of jobs I mentioned
the uncertainty of regulation taxes are
a big one well the tax the rates
established back in 2003 continuing to
foul after or the end of this year I
think they will a lot of Democrats are
coming up for reelection in 2012 22 in
the Senate suddenly they're seeing the
light they would like to stay in
Washington so I think that will be done
but we'll have to see but there are a
lot of other uncertainties out there so
that's why this has been a subpar
recovery if the government had done
nothing you'd have had a more job
creation and a more vigorous recovery
and I think that's what's going to help
spark and debate again it's not the need
for a lack it's not we don't need
government James Madison was right we
are angels we'd not need government
we're manifesting not angels so we need
laws need government
the only angels around or maybe some of
us all to have grandchildren and that's
only up to a certain age and and but the
you do need laws but the question is
what is the proper role of government to
create an environment where you get
maximum innovation and development and
new janu new businesses and new big
businesses remember businesses start
small but you need a handful and become
big to compete in the world so you're
you're at the font of research and to
have that bear fruit you need the proper
environment and that's what I think is
going to be debated in the next few
years positively I want to pursue this
last point but before we do I want to go
back to health care because I know
you've got some strong opinions about
that I'm guessing you're not a fan the
administration's health care reform bill
and you've gathered that yeah just one
sentence from one of the many things
you've written on the topic we could
help the uninsured get access to
coverage but we have to be smart about
well Everett of it well I think the just
quick thing on health care ask ourselves
why do we have a health care crisis and
people say well we want more of it baby
boomers coming along wanting more and
more of it but think about it any other
part of the economy people want more of
something it's seen as an opportunity
that people want more cars Detroit would
be very happy to supply might now people
want more software a lot of software
writers would be very happy to supply it
more apps a lot of people willing to
provide new apps what's with health care
why is this demand for healthcare seen
as a disaster instead of a growth
opportunity it gets to the real basic
oven this gets to those safety nets gets
the real basic of it is the way we
finance it it's all third-party there's
a disconnect between providers and
consumers and we have we have a swath of
health care that is free enterprise free
markets which is why we still produce
more new drugs more new medical devices
and the rest of the world put together
puts a skewed system and the proof of it
it's because we grew up with it we don't
think it's strange but if you go to a
doctor a hospital or a clinic you ask in
advance what a cause
look at you very strangely means one of
two things either you're uninsured or
you're a lunatic why why would you want
to know the price what's it to you and
think about strange that is imagine
going a restaurant saying ordering a
bottle of wine thinking I don't care
what it costs that's a Blue Shield's
problem blue crying I don't care
Medicare let them worry about it so the
system gets skewed and so the key thing
there is to get more free enterprise and
health care and then in terms of safety
nets anything answer your question on
food foods more basic than health no no
no no food no anything yet if people
have trouble getting food in this
country we don't have the government
taking over the farms if we did there'd
be no more obesity we'd all be starving
they they they they they they tried that
they tried that in in Russia and China
with the horrific results so we allow
farmers to grow the food companies
process the food Heinz and others we
truckers deliberate restaurants hotels
and supermarkets and grocery stores sell
the food people can't get it you have
everything from food stamps to food
banks to help out why can't we do the
same thing in healthcare 35 states have
high-risk pools how Obamacare has them
but it's it's it's a temporary thing why
not elaborate on those why not expand on
those why not have if you need to
assistance for low-income people in
high-risk pools their various ways you
can do it and that's where on the state
level you can find out what works just
as Wisconsin proved in the 1990s that
welfare reform could work then was
adopted nationally why don't we do that
and find out what works and then do it
nationally get the best of both worlds
productivity innovation less cost and
safety nuts we did it with food we can
do with health care but the governor can
I do it I'm sure who I get some
questions from the audience on this yes
I want it I want to get as many topics
sort of out on the table so that people
can pursue them as shifting gears pretty
significant
here by any measure Forbes today under
your leadership has become truly a
global enterprise we've got forbesasia
Forbes Korea Forbes Russia towards China
Forbes Israel orbs Poland Turkey and I'm
sure many other forms X where X is dis
about any other country globalization
very interesting question one that has
many dimensions and is viewed very
differently by different people
depending on where they sit and an issue
great interest to this University your
thoughts about globalization good in bed
but in a sense we've been globalizing
since we moved out of caves thousands of
years ago globalization is simply
another way of saying you expand your
contacts you expand commerce with others
and as technology develops and politics
allows it it does circle the world we
saw that in the 19th century first world
war depression interrupted it Cold War
took a good chunk of the world out of it
but since the fall of the Berlin Wall
we've had a huge increase and it's
hugely positive literally until this
crazy economic crisis which was totally
unnecessary each year tens of millions
of people around the world started to
join the middle class and so it's a it's
only a threat in the sense that any
economy that grows and changes you have
to adapt to it and take advantage of it
instead of trying to stop the clock
which China did centuries ago and paid a
severe price for it it's a positive
thing that's the wonderful thing about
free markets it's not zero sum your gain
is not at the expense of somebody else
and so free markets can be disruptive
but we've learned over time you can go
with those disruptions and have a cheap
immensely higher standard of living and
more and more opportunity
we're certainly seeing it in the media
industry today disruption which shrimp
that are called creative destruction
creative parts nice the destruction part
is not so nice but adjusting to to to a
new environment so globalization is a
good thing and one of the things that I
hope comes after these midterm elections
is this trend towards protectionism we
almost got in trade with China over a
misunderstanding with currencies are and
we we did it in 1930s which was a
disaster gave us a global depression
allowing people to buy where they want
from whom they want is a positive thing
and so up and then the just to put
another plug for free markets throw a
grenade out contrary to the idea of
markets being soulless markets are
people and free markets actually prayed
more humanity they break down ethnic and
racial and national barriers just one
example is Northern Ireland 300 years
Catholics and Protestants killing each
other they have a precarious piece there
right now it wasn't just great diplomacy
it was the boom in the Republic of
Ireland that changed the diet political
dynamics in Northern Ireland huge
prosperity Ireland went from the weakest
economy in Europe as it changes they
made to the most dynamic yes they're
hard hit by this recession but they will
come out of it that changed the dynamic
in northern ireland and pj o'rourke the
humorist put it very well he said it
wasn't that the catholics and
protestants loved each other there's
just too many things on the to-do list
before they could go go about killing
each other you know got to get the kids
to soccer practice do get the house
repaired mortgage paid so blowing up
your neighbor just you couldn't get to
it just too many other things to do what
are you saying in a much more humorous
way than I can convey it is that you
change the dynamic you create new forces
that focus on creating rather than
committing violence against one another
I want to connect this threat of
globalization with your point about
constructive government as opposed to
dis garment and focus it on the dhikr
issue of competitiveness national
competitiveness it's an issue of great
interest to research universities we
think of ourselves as the engine of the
nation's competitiveness a real job
generator through the technology we
create and the people that we graduate
we depend very heavily on government
support for them government investments
in basic research and believe that those
investments are key to the nation's
competitors I'd like to hear your
thoughts in general about
competitiveness but and job creation in
that sense but in particular would this
fall under your constructive government
heading up the the first part on
competitiveness how you create it is
having an environment or with sensible
rules of the road where people have a
maximum freedom to try things create
things as you know most new businesses
fail but its product from that messy
process seemingly wasteful process that
the good things come along and it's not
just in high technology it can be in the
most mundane areas for example you go to
Starbucks or similar coffee place they
have 12 ounce cups 16 ounce cups and 20
ounce cups you notice the lids are all
the same size little thing like that
those little things are constant in a
vibrant economy that to improve things
make things a little easier and so you
know that gets to taxation lower rates
simplification sound currency
regulations that allow you to focus on
your business instead of filling out
forms all day or having to hire people
to do it and then in terms of the role
of government yes government can do and
help basic research as long as it
realizes it's just basic research and
not try to dominate they
research after all the internet came out
of the Defense Department DARPA were
very now a purpose the mainframe
computer at a world war two to help
calculate the better of trajectories for
artillery shells much more broader
applications where you threw it out into
the marketplace but you also have to be
very careful just one example is I think
it's from the national institutes of the
sciences I forget the number they do in
terms of grants but one of the strange
things about science and mathematics is
often not always but often the most
creative work is done when your 20s and
30s maybe 40s so rub it in but that's
why you're president overseeing the
young people how to gain my stuff letter
that but but but you see Einstein and
others and so and yet you look at the
average age of the grants coming the
average age is 59 which means it's going
to politically safe no one's going to
say oh this person is worthy of a
government grant but it's just really
doing stuff on the tweaking rather than
the fundamental breakthroughs so yes it
has a role but it better not be the
chief source because it tends to go for
again political trajectories safety
because if you give money to somebody in
this 20s there's something that looks
utterly idiotic because it fails you get
in political trouble whereas if you do
it on because you have the you're doing
it in the private sector okay you took a
risk it didn't work out it's it's your
loss but nobody else's it's not doesn't
have political repercussions so yes
there is a role going way back to
Jefferson having Lewis and Clark find
out what he just bought from the
Louisiana Purchase so but again it has
to be a narrow focus because otherwise
it will go into a direction that you
don't want the inherent Krishna here at
conservatism of the granting process in
our basic research h ceases a fair
criticism I think you're right on that
we would tend to agree with it there's a
lot more to pursue along this line but I
am committed to opening this up to the
audience right around this time but I
can't resist one more question to go
back to Tuesday's election hmm
implications of what you saw on Tuesday
and we're seeing this week for 2012 in
the presidential election and I be
remiss if I didn't ask and are you gonna
run again the answer is no I'm an
agitator now and the much more fun being
a Tom Paine as long as you stay away
from revolutionary France get a lot of
constructive things done but no and the
thing about 2012 and the Republican
Party is precisely it is wide open I'd
learned the hard way the GOP is a party
where you wait your turn and 222 2008
was McCain's turn 2000 was george w
stern 96 with bob dole's turn this time
there is no turn it is truly wide open
mit romney has huge problems with what
he did with health care in massachusetts
you can you can go down the list of all
those are looking at it and you can
easily find the negatives and so it's
going to be an interesting process to
see who emerges from it there will be a
candidate and just remind my Republican
colleagues in terms of unpopularity of
the president is that something that
fellow named Bob Strauss was an old
Washington hand said in the early 1970s
when he did a brief stint as chairman of
the Democratic Party Strauss said we
Democrats could beat Nixon in a
landslide Richard Nixon was president if
we didn't have to run anyone against him
yeah they they they they did after on
somebody and that somebody lost by a
landslide so it's not a given that the
GOP Oh cramp in 2012 and it'll be very
interesting one of the things that takes
real political skill is we know some of
us least
think we see certain forces rupp ting in
this country can they be channeled in a
positive way Reagan did it in the early
80s starting from the eruptions in the
70s if you don't it can go very nasty
and very negative if people feel it's a
becoming futile and nobody responds so
we'll see how it works out and usually
it works out in this country with one
glaring exception which was I don't
think politics could have done anyway
civil war but usually the whole our
system this is a whole nother subject
it's designed in a way to take a very
heterogeneous population in terms of
interests and mold them into a
coalitions that can govern and you can't
win the presidency is a sectional
candidate or a narrow base candidate you
have to bring in a lot of people who may
not like each other and that that I
think is a very real strength of the
American system just give you one
example and we'll open it up is when I
ran you know in nineteen first round in
1996 just the difference between the
Republican Party in Iowa and the
republican party in New Hampshire same
party same country same language in Iowa
this is generalization but I think it
holds true Republicans are profoundly
interested in social issues that is
paramount he sought reason the last
election where they tossed out statewide
three justices who had devoted for gay
marriage very big on social issues New
Hampshire the exact opposite they
couldn't care less all they care about
is don't touch my guns and don't
increase my taxes rest of it just leave
me alone and so so just take abortion in
Iowa you get a very very pro-life result
New Hampshire very pro-choice results
same party and yet very very diverse
interests and again the political system
for all of its flaws finds ways to bring
very diverse people together for at
least temporary shared purposes and
that's why the country is not flown
apart which could very easily
thank you here's your chance just uh
step right up to the microphone and ask
your question I very interesting remarks
mr. Forbes I wonder if you would suggest
any ways that the federal spending could
or should be cut and how you'd go about
doing that two trillion dollar problem
of course um well the answer is there's
a lot that can be cut that most people
wouldn't miss their numerous everyone
talks about it but nothing ever gets
done about it because you're always
traipsing over somebody subcommittee in
Congress but their numerous duplicate of
programs numerous things you could ask
is this money achieving the results that
it's supposed to achieve I'll even take
education K through 12 is that money
well spent I don't think so which is why
I'm an advocate of charter schools but
but in the Heritage Foundation I sit on
the board full disclosure came out you
can find it on their site suggestions
for at least three hundred seventy
billion of cuts that you could do
without disrupting the civilization they
just asked do half of them under an 85
billion and things like don't spend the
tarp money when it comes in don't wreath
don't shovel it out again the amount of
money left unspent from the stimulus
don't spend it and then but that gets to
the entitlements which won't be dealt
with I don't think in this Congress but
will have to be dealt with after 2012
there are two ways to deal with
entitlements one is what you might call
root canal without anesthesia that is
say on Social Security raise the
retirement age to 90 problem solved on
Medicare on Medicare shoot everyone
above the age of 75 problem solved but
there I think you think there are more
positive ways to deal with it just since
we don't have all afternoon on health
care those huge liabilities of Medicaid
and Medicare assumed little or no
productivity
health care you open up the system to
more free markets with those safety nets
you start to get some productivity those
numbers come crashing down on social
security I think for younger people the
only answer is have your own personal
accounts both of the payroll tax go into
your accounts you hone them proper rules
and diversification and the like you
know you can't invest in racetracks and
tie lenders stuff like that and that's
the way to go if you want to discuss it
more be happy to but they're positive
ways to deal with entitlements without
going the root canal way which is what
I'm afraid they're going to do at least
initially in Washington I meant to say
at the outset that was a very good
question that should be your model and
we're looking for questions not
diatribes or a long commentary so
question yes ok- own introduce myself my
name is mr. Patrick will have an alumnus
of this university as you can see i'm
still a little shaken over congressman
john hall sauce I grew up actually grew
up in this district I think a lot of
people you know especially the young
people then turn out for the election
because of all the negative advertising
yeah I saw all the mudslinging people in
two counties Ian and hey were throwing
mud at each other and unfortunately Hall
lost I actually originally supported
because of the alternative energy
research uh is let me talk about about
the ferry we're getting to a question
now yeah the new Congress the question
uh with Republicans taking over of the
house representatives is they're gonna
how can how can they work together with
the president and the Democrats because
a the pressure for all young people's
that they're getting sick and tired
these politics because you know
Democrats and Republicans see me
throwing pies at each other shouting out
at each other things like that and i can
get for young people in globalized good
question cannot be congress and the
president work together up but first in
terms of political messiness I think
this Bismarck who said there are two
things that people should never see
being made one is sausages the other is
laws it is not a very edifying process
but in terms of the mudslinging whenever
you have a political situation where
there's not a consensus or general
consensus about how things are done at
the elbows get very sharp and all you
have to do to see how sharp they can get
as look at our founders after they
establish this republican 1789 in the
1790s in the early part of the 19th
century the politics was very poisonous
in this country and one of the greatest
practitioners of this poison was one
Thomas Jefferson in terms of the
skewering Hamilton and others and the
Federalists responded in kind because
they knew the stakes were huge they're
establishing precedents and we've had
other periods the 1930s the 70s where
thing think things were pretty rough so
I think you have to see it in the
context that very basic questions are
out there what should be the role of
government what kind of health care
system should we have what have can we
have a financial system that allows room
for a small banks which the one of the
maybe unintended consequences both this
financial reform bill simply
consolidates the biggies and
consolidates too big to fail so when you
have these kind of basic questions don't
be surprised where people have
differences that spills over especially
in the campaign especially now we have
sound bites don't be surprised is going
to get very sharp but I think in what it
does though will create a new consensus
which will last maybe for a generation
and then change comes along and people
that read abate these things but in
terms of working with the president well
the present make substantial changes in
this health care bill I don't think so
he will on the 1099 provision which
would have killed small businesses he
indicated that in his press conference
but on the rest of the bill I think it's
going to be ultimately decided by the
electorate as to what kind of a sit
where where where we go in health care
on taxes I think they may get an
agreement on an extension of the tax
cuts not because the president wants to
be because his own party looking ahead
to 2012 wants to get this issue of tax
increases off the table they know its
political poison so things get done in
this country and sometimes untidy ways
just give you one quick example social
security was not invented in response to
the plight of elderly people during the
Great Depression the real reason that
got created the way it did in as fast as
it did was because of something called
the Townsend movement ever have insomnia
at night and want to look up something
look up the Townsend movement very
obscure but anyway it's swept the
country this guy dr. Townsend came up
with the idea of a big tax new tax
regime that would give everyone above
the age of 60 thousands of dollars a
year which would be the equivalent of
fifty or hundred thousand dollars a year
today huge political movement to head
off that political movement Roosevelt
decided to go with something where
seemingly very small compared to what
Townsend wanted which was Social
Security that was the impetus for the
Social Security Bill that's what often
happens is pressure groups people
agitating for things and things happen
it's never as it portrayed in the movies
ah we must do this yes and the disease
part it's all too human all too messy so
be part of it and don't get discouraged
by it especially now a social networking
it's easy now to get together
like-minded people discuss things and
decide what can we do about something
and things that's how things emerge
again not always edifying but in a
freewheeling democracy it usually works
almost I'm over here
it's enough um so I'm kind of curious uh
one of the things I've noticed is that
there's a bit of a trade imbalance
between America and particularly
manufacturing companies countries like
China and I my sense was that that was
one of the reason why the value of the
dollar had to decline what do you think
of the trade imbalance would think
implications of it might be and where do
you see us in countries like China and
other manufacturing company is going
since I'm not running for anything I'll
love I'll answer it this way there's no
trade imbalance in the world it all
works out and not to be facetious on it
but Forbes magazine has had a trade
imbalance with our paper suppliers for
93 years we buy more paper from our
paper suppliers and they buy
subscriptions to Forbes so no I'm making
a serious point you making a serious
point if you just look at that number
just look at that number and say oh my
god what a disaster if you look at the
whole balance sheet you look at the
whole P&L statement you'll see yeah we
have a trade imbalance with that
supplier but we have a trade surpluses
with others in terms of international
trade you cannot look just at
merchandise trade obviously have to look
at services but you also have to look at
the flow of capital capital is a good
and we've been in a capital of Porter
for most of our history because we are a
more open economy and so if you look at
the last four hundred years and we
celebrated Jamestown a couple of years
ago 1607 since Jamestown versus colonies
an independent country we've had a trade
imbalance we just look at merchandise at
350 out of the last 400 years and but
because we had capitals coming in it
didn't it balances out now with the case
of China and by the way it also these
trade figures also overlooked not only
capital but investment overseas for
example
intel has a facility in Malaysia that
sells product to Japan that does not
show up on our trade numbers but it's an
american-based company and obviously
that's that's that's good for Intel so
you got to look at the whole thing in
terms of are you innovative are you
creating jobs are you have an
environment where companies can start
and grow to be big companies mention the
1970s terrible decade look loose liquid
was a warning you I mean they're
starting to birth you had Microsoft
Apple Oracle sun microsystems Amgen you
had Charles Schwab Southwest Airlines
FedEx as soon as you got a benign
environment in the 80s those companies
took off so that's what you want that
kind of environment in terms of China
another thing at work is because of
global supply chains a lot of stuff
that's Creator created out of China goes
into China for final assembly and then
shipped to the US so a lot of trade
imbalance that we might have had with
the Malaysia or a South Korea or others
now get shifted because of the way we
booked these things to China said China
is not that you know it's a
manufacturing major manufacturing
country but not that big and so and then
the other thing that's skewing these
trade figures capital flows is the cheap
dollar huge transfer of wealth to a
country's some of them we don't like
because of when we trash our dollars and
that's why again trashing the dawn on
the early part of the last decade is why
we've had a decade where the capital
markets equity markets have gone nowhere
for the standard of living has stagnated
we saw the same thing in the 70s and
when when you start to muck around with
that so keep 60 looks like minutes in an
hour imagine what your life would be
like if we floated the hour like we do
the dollar sixty minutes an hour one day
80 minutes the next 30 minutes the next
you soon have to have hedges through it
as futures to figure out how many hours
you work in each week just make it
simple so and then the other thing on
China is current it's like let me make
simple we're we're here in pencil
vania does anyone know at Pennsylvania's
trade deficit is with New Jersey for
surplus does anyone care know what you
want to know is how we doing and and you
know we don't have a new jersey dollar
Pennsylvania dollar China fixed its
currency to the dollar fifteen years ago
in effect outsourced you want to the
Federal Reserve and that should be a
good thing because you don't you don't
get well by arbitrarily putting on taxes
or changing arbitrarily change the price
of things and one example and then we'll
get the next question but it's very very
important because we don't we don't get
this right with China it could have very
real bad repercussions and that is we
tried this with Japan we noticed we had
a merchandise trade episode of Japan so
in the 80s and 90s we beat the Japanese
too low to increase the value of the ND
value of a dollar diva the dollars now
worth twenty cents of what a 20-percent
of twenty five percent of what it was
against the yen 25 years ago we still
have a merchandise trade deficit with
Japan these things don't work in the
long run in to make it simple if you buy
a bottle of wine if you sell a bottle of
wine for four loaves of bread you
suddenly notice you're only getting two
you're going to change the price again
to get the equivalent of four same thing
is with trade you change the value of
your currency yeah that may give you a
temporary boost but it increases your
cost of production increases of latian
airy forces does not work so if China I
think that thing would work itself out
if instead we focused on reducing trade
berries with China they block a lot of
our product and services and if we
stabilize the dollar so we get less of
shoveling of assets overseas
unnecessarily I think that thing would
start to a correct itself but doing
doing it through trade fooling with the
currency very very destructive it's bad
that we want a cheap dollar we tried
that in the 30s beggar thy neighbor it
doesn't lead to good things
hi I'm back oh gosh beer for sure
policies I was
also your egg is about making it easier
for businesses and I guess right now
there's not a lot of not a lot of small
insurance companies for instance if one
in the free market does choose insurance
over just paying for stuff themselves
and so I guess the question is do would
you advocate a policy that would make
everyone have the same price for
services the hospital or something like
that or would you have some other idea
of how how small businesses or small
insurance companies could start or be
allowed to innovate in this space in
terms of your question on the insurers
one of the things we should do is allow
nationwide shopping for insurance I live
in New Jersey we have a lot of crazy
regulations you may not realize that
Pennsylvania has less crazy regulations
I can buy a policy in Pennsylvania
virtually equivalent to one in New
Jersey about fifty to sixty percent of
what I have to pay in New Jersey but I'm
not allowed to buy here in Pennsylvania
I can buy a car in Pennsylvania or a
house but I can't buy the insurance
let's have nationwide shopping that does
several things when you get true
competition because people then have the
whole nation 1100 companies competing it
also opens up the space for true
innovators who may come in with a policy
would appeal to young people
catastrophic insurance since young
people believe they're immortal the
policy would not force you to get
insurance for hair implants or marriage
counseling but just before if you have a
serious illness or accident very very
cheap especially if you're young
companies that offer that and they see
it in other areas like retailing you
know 40 years ago 50 years ago Walmart
was 150th the size of kmart but because
they did high-tech in terms of managing
inventories and all of the supply chains
better they went from a small Northwest
Arkansas retailer to the biggest
retailer in the world
that's what the competition you would
see and in terms of the hospitals and
what they charge you're going to see I
think more specialization people
focusing on a specific area for example
I see a little bit of a now in New York
Hospital for Special Surgery focuses
solely on your knees your hips athletic
injuries and the like they're the best
one of the best in the world you I just
had back surgery there now they don't do
cancer cures you have another hospital
new york sloan-kettering the focus is
only on cancer and that tries to make
breakthroughs there so you want to see
allow that kind of specialization get
breakthroughs getting innovations and
what the prices are will be determined
by the market and one of the things
you'll see is that that these
innovations real prices are going to
come down just give you two quick
examples LASIK surgery for the eyes
that's not usually covered and so you
have to write the check yourself because
you write the check providers up every
incentive to make it more affordable to
you and so cost less in real terms than
it did ten years ago another example
cosmetic surgery none of you need it
pander but but but but in the last 15
years cosmetic surgeon this country's
increased six-fold major innovations
especially in burns and yet it costs you
haven't had the kind of inflation there
that bed and rest of healthcare why
because it's unless it's a result of
disease or accident you're writing the
check so the providers again have every
incentive so if you want a procedure you
scope it out like you do anything else
you have friends that can keep the mouth
shut you might ask them for advice and
so the system works so that's what you
want to do you don't want price-fixing
you want the kind of thing that the
Steve Jobs is of the world going into
health care and coming up with you
Nevada blazoned you see little pockets
of it for example flu shots normally
you'd have to go to a doctor in an
appointment now at airports you go there
your plane's delayed nothing abnormal
about that spend 35 bucks get the flu
shot
walmart for dollar prescriptions why
don't we have more of that kind of those
innovations or allowing states that put
a kibosh on most entrepreneurs who
wanted to create little facilities with
registered nurses where you'd go if you
have a cut or something and the going
get a quick fix with something more
serious they have the knowledge medical
knowledge to send you to the emergency
room but for a lot of stuff it's just in
and out instead of making an appointment
hoping get an appoint with the doc blah
blah blah I just go in to the if so I
think there's a whole way of innovation
so a little be little be a lot of things
happening a word of warning to those
standing the mics we are we have a very
hard stop time of 4 30 because mr. he
has to get the short okay oh no that was
which means were piling they have one
more question but do standards the case
you I have a fairly open ended question
but if you were in then Bernanke's shoes
over the course of the Fanta crisis how
would you have handled it what do you
think and going forward would you do to
um good question very good question very
interesting one because Ben Bernanke
along with alan greenspan went along
with this dollar debasement starting the
early part of the last decade so if I
wasn't issues I'd realize I made a big
mistake and go to a strong and stable
dollar policy not do what they call qe2
quality quantitative easing to these are
Roman numeral this is big stuff qe2 qqe
to should just be the name of a ship
some of you old enough remember Queen
Elizabeth to qe2 regular too but but but
sudden the way you do it is when you
stop pushing on a string you know
there's a lot of liquidity in the system
shoveling out another 600 billion just
to Storch the Treasury bond market that
punishes savers because you get no
interest for saving and hurt small
businesses in a peculiar way so uh stop
that and announced from now on you're
going to have a
stable dollar policy and I'll throw
something out that will make the
Economist here gag most of them but so
be it I see the exit and that is and
that is I'll predict that in the next
few years you're going to see a new
monetary system emerged where for the
first time since the early 70s there
will be a link between dollar and gold
it's going to happen has to happen time
for one last question questions along
the same lines how do you think
quantitative easing to is going to
impact living standards in the United
States and what impact will it have on
the global economy what will qe2 have on
living standards it will help perpetuate
stagnation and living standards because
it's not going to get the capital
markets workings they should again it
hurts small businesses right now we have
a financial system where if you're a
large company you can get money very
easily and very cheap if you're a small
company many of them it's very unfair
heed I see whether you can get a
reliable line of credit a working
capital for expansion capital if you're
a bank and you make a loan to a small
business the regulator's going to ask
you going to really put you through the
paces what kind of collateral is there
what the business went broke and they
they just make it you you make it very a
very hostile environment for a flow of a
reliable flow of credit to small
businesses so whenever the system that
gives ask you to large companies gives a
skewed of government hurt small
businesses hurt startups a long term
that that's a very very bad formula and
globally what that announces to the
world is we want to still want a cheap
dollar and that's why there's a race to
a cheapening your currency we haven't
seen anything like it since the 1930s
we're nowheres near the kind of disaster
we had then but this is the kind of
thing that can spiral out of control
unless there's real leadership that says
the dollars got to be stable the US has
to take the lead in terms of things like
moving again on free trade
I'll be blunt here is the first time
since World War two we haven't had a
government that is actively pushing free
trade every Democrat every Republican
president since world war two has been a
free trader you know they make some
tactical move sometimes on protectionism
for political reasons but the emphasis
has been on removing trade barriers and
Bill Clinton went against his own party
mid-1990s to get the North American Free
Trade Agreement go to deal with
Republicans get that through because he
knew the importance of free trade I hope
the president goes to Asia and gets an
earful from the South Koreans he'll come
back and truly push the free trade
agreement we negotiated years ago a
South Korea Colombia Panama and put a
real new renewed emphasis on reducing
barriers because if we don't take the
lead on it it's a it's not going to be
not going to be good for us and for the
rest of the world again we saw what
happened in the 30s why we would want to
even risk that again is a mystery said
to be one of the fastest hours in my
life I can't believe we went through we
had our that quickly I have about 20
more questions and like we multiply that
by several times over the virtue of God
nails I was fascinating thank you so
much Steve please join me in thanking
Steve
you